welcome back to CBS morning's now to A
Story of Friendship hope and giving back
that as you'll see comes full circle in
a remarkable Way Tucker Haas was just
two years old when he was diagnosed with
a rare form of cancer fraternity members
at nearby Penn State University took him
under their wing Haas now a senior at
Penn State himself is joining the fight
with another young boy facing a similar
battle Nancy Chan traveled to State
College Pennsylvania to see how Haas is
paying it forward Nancy good morning
Nate good morning to you life for Tucker
Haas has not been easy by any means but
you wouldn't know that by speaking with
him instead he is filled with optimism
and now using his story to give hope to
others
Tucker Haas is on a full circle journey
and the path keeps leading him here to
State College Pennsylvania what does
Penn State mean to you Penn State saved
my life at the age of two Haas was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
sarcoma in total I went through four
different stints with cancer twice
inside my face and twice in my right
lung but I had two floor economy
surgeries 77 radiation treatments
hundreds of chemotherapy treatments but
his family has never ever seen a medical
bill and that's because of a partnership
between Four Diamonds a Childhood Cancer
Research and support organization in
Thon the Penn State student-run
philanthropic effort known most notably
for its 46-hour dance Marathon
fundraiser
young and ambitious
[Music]
on collects goes to children and their
families impacted by cancer
as a nine-year-old Haas even
participated in the event in this viral
moment
[Applause]
this will be your 20th on this year yeah
you've been going since you were really
little yeah it's just one of those
things when you walk into Thon if you've
never experienced it uh it's very
breathtaking seeing 15 plus thousand
students packed at the Bryce Jordan
Center on a snowy freezing cold weekend
in February and you just see all these
kids with the same passion the same love
for these children and families that are
going through cancer but the support it
goes far beyond one night through Thon a
sorority and fraternity also adopted
Haas as one of their own what would they
do for you
I mean everything they would come visit
me at the hospital and drive two hours
on a weekend and spend the entire
weekend with me they would send me stuff
to the hospital toys and presents
looking back it really made an impact in
my life Haas has been cancer-free for
almost 16 years when it came time to
apply for college he says Penn State was
a no-brainer
now a senior he's a leader in the very
same fraternity that looked after him as
a kid Alpha Tau Omega and he's giving
back to kids just like him
three-year-old Gus Baumgardner was
diagnosed with cancer at just two years
old Four Diamonds is paying for the now
three-year-old's treatment I don't know
how they do it because it's not even
like we get bills and we submit them we
don't get bills like at all Greta
Baumgardner is Gus's mom she credits a
support from Penn State and Haas himself
for helping carry their family through
this battle when you hear about Tucker's
story that not only did he successfully
beat Childhood Cancer but that he is
thriving like this what does that mean
to you it gave us some hope because
Tucker's Tucker had a hard hard journey
too and to see him many years later and
he's living a life that has purpose that
he is happy and content even with
everything he's gone through has given
us a lot of Hope do you see yourself in
these kids yeah
especially Gus if you probably put a
picture of the two of us side by side
two two-year-old little boys with bald
heads with so much energy the love of
life I'm here and now I'm able to
kind of get back to the families like us
it's neat to see it come full circle the
full circle moment in this story was
almost complete as Haas reflected on the
college students who looked after him
when he endured his own battle they made
a big difference in your life yeah for
sure
some people are still guys that I talk
to now they now have children of their
own so that's that's crazy to see they
really did help change your life yeah
what would you say if I told you
they were standing behind you right now
no way
we arranged a surprise visit with these
now men who were in their late teens and
early 20s when their fraternity first
adopted Haas Museum grow up yeah what
has that been like you're crazy that's
insane I mean you think of him I think
of him as a three four five-year-old you
know I'm coming back to see this it's
insane he calls you guys Role Models but
you guys also think of him as a role
model absolutely yes
source of strength for everybody yeah
what him and his family have done
sharing their story with uh countless
different pledge classes have come
through the fraternity to thawn itself I
mean he's an inspiration to all of us
Hawker was what brought us together Haas
graduates this spring with a sports
management degree he's not sure yet
where it'll take him but he hopes to
continue to inspire others what do you
want people to learn from you and your
story there's always a light at the end
of the tunnel I went through my journey
with cancer for a reason I'm at Penn
State for a reason it all just eyes in
itself like why I'm here and why I have
the opportunity to do what I'm doing
and Tucker Tuckers will raise money on
behalf of his fraternity and a sorority
for Thon this year he has a goal of half
a million dollars in organization record
Gus who we introduced you to is now
eight months post-treatment and his mom
says his latest scans showed no evidence
of cancer but you know in talking to
Tucker he said all these hundreds of
college kids that you are strangers
essentially have become your biggest
support system and your biggest
cheerleaders it's a powerful example of
the good that can be done from
sororities and fraternities you know
we've done stories about the opposite
yeah this is a wonderful counter example
as soon as I saw those men sneak up
behind Tucker I said oh it's too early
to be crying like this Nancy a tearful
eight o'clock hour for sure and you know
it was a surprise but at the same time
they've stayed in touch for all these
years since so many full circle moments
in that in that story nicely done Nancy
Chen good to have you as always